love will abide
take things and stride
sounds like good advice
all I really want to do is sing and I'm
I really am delighted when when other
people like it I mean I couldn't be more
pleased
Love's wounds unseen
that's what someone told me
but I don't know what it means I don't
like the idea of having to be a cultural
determinant you know or you know a
a culture hero or a role model or
anything like that you know I don't want
to be the the absolute last word and
what the trendy style is but I just want
to sing that's all I ever wanted to do
that's all I can remember ever wanting
to do when I was a little girl my
earliest memory is just begging my
father to sit down and play his guitar
and sing something for me or to please
turn the record player on
cause I done everything I know
to try and make you mine
I wanted to be a singer when I left home
I didn't want to be a star I mean
there's a real difference you know when
a child comes up to me and said can you
tell me how to be a star I say well
honey I don't have anything to say to
you you know I just don't know how to
help you somebody comes up and says do
you want I want to be a singer when I
grow up then I can give them some advice
I think it's a real difference I always
wanted to sing if I can make my living
singing I consider myself a success you
know if I don't have to go and get a day
job then I'm successful I think I'm
gonna lie
for a long
long
time with music following your Melissa
just singing the songs that you think
sound good you know regardless of what's
in style regardless of what
you know the market dictates that you do
if you follow your bliss you usually
will make a right decision if you don't
follow your bliss you won't be able to
sell it anyway that's what I think
oh no wait don't leave it leave it oh
this is good this is Linda Ronstadt do
you know Linda Ronstadt is you know I
don't know
the purpose of art is to make order is
to try to make sense out of life and
life is Relentless it's it's often sad
and difficult to deal with
it probably gets harder as you go along
and I think what art is is a series of
patterns of some kind of that assumes
some kind of classic form that help you
reorder the way that you perceive your
existence and they help you sift it out
into some kind of recognizable landscape
that you know instead of just chaos out
there it's there to help you make order
out of chaos and that's what I use music
for
[Music]
[Applause]
I've done everything I know
try and change your mind
and I think I'm gonna love you
for long
long
[Music]
time